queridos amigos no os lo habéis pedido
un montón de veces que hablemos mucho
más de américa latina'
[Música]
pues bien ya tenemos una solución os
presentamos la tan política un año es
letter que hemos preparado junto a la
consultora page perspective
si te suscribes cada mes podrás recibir
12 boletines con la mejor información y
los mejores análisis sobre américa
latina para que así estés al día y
entiendas mejor todo lo que ocurre en
esta región
el coste puedes suscribirte por menos de
30 céntimos de euro por cada boletín
menos de un café a la semana a cambio
estarás al tanto de los principales
acontecimientos que ocurran en
latinoamérica y conocerás todas sus
implicaciones además todos los que nos
apoyáis en el nivel 4 y 5 de patriot
recibir y zlatan política a coste cero
tenéis toda la info en latam
político.com
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en ocasiones sucede que las personas más
insospechadas terminan dando la
campanada y convirtiéndose en los
protagonistas sorpresa de la fiesta
queridos amigos amigas puede que esta
frase sea una de las que mejor resumen
el paso de lenin moreno por la
presidencia del ecuador
[Música]
hablamos de un hombre que durante más de
6 años fue vicepresidente del mismísimo
rafael correa- de un político que llegó
al palacio de carondelet la casa blanca
ecuatoriana entre acusaciones de fraude
para mantener en pie en contra viento y
marea al correísmo pero que sin embargo
al poco tiempo se negó completamente del
legado de su profesor un legado que
dicho sea de paso le ponía moreno la
presidencia bastante pero que bastante
movidita y es que veréis al terminar el
gobierno de correa ecuador se encontraba
en una situación muy pero que muy
delicada consumidor los más 60.000
millones de dólares ingresados gracias
al boom de los precios del petróleo la
economía ecuatoriana entró en una
espiral de crisis desequilibrios
presupuestarios y deuda pública tenemos
casi 75 mil millones de dólares nos toca
pagar el 10 por ciento más capital de
esa cantidad casi 11 mil millones de
dólares anuales en servicio de la deuda
lenin moreno presidente de ecuador claro
que los desajustes macroeconómicos no
son lo único que se encontró lenin
moreno cuando se hizo con la presidencia
pero ahora su tiempo ha pasado cuatro
años después de llegar al poder de
ecuador se desliza hacia una nueva era
bajo una nueva presidencia y la pregunta
que podemos hacernos
que ecuador deja lenin moreno a su
sucesor os apetece saber cómo ha sido el
paso de este presidente por el palacio
de carondelet pues arranquemos
la ruptura
la presidencia de moreno empezó con una
idea muy claramente ecuador estaba muy
mal económicamente y hacía falta mucho
dinero y para conseguirlo pues no
quedaba otra había que desligarse del
bloque del socialismo del siglo 21
latinoamericano y demostrar así que el
nuevo gobierno no era como el de correa
ni tampoco como venezuela bolivia o la
argentina kirchnerista no me interesa el
poder me interesa el bienestar de todos
me interesa el presente y futuro de
ecuador me interesa el país en el que
vivirán nuestros hijos y nietos el
futuro de nuestros mayores
lenin moreno presidente de ecuador sin
embargo tras más de 10 años de gobierno
de rafael correa esa no hay base de una
tarea precisamente fácil por ejemplo
entre los principales escollos estaba la
enorme desconfianza de los inversores
internacionales hacia un país que en el
año 2008 había anunciado el impago de la
deuda un impago ojo que no se produjo
por un problema económico o financiero
en aquel momento sino por una cuestión
simple pura y llanamente política e
ideológica de la noche a la mañana los
inversores internacionales se
encontraron con noticias como esta
entonces de diciembre de 2008 ecuador
dice quién pagará su deuda extranjera
evidentemente pues si no pagas tus
deudas no esperes que te vuelvan a
prestar y si lo hacen te va a tocar
pagar unos intereses elevadísimos y eso
eso es exactamente lo que ocurrió de tal
forma que cuando el precio del petróleo
comenzó a venirse abajo en 2014 la
economía ecuatoriana cio poco a poco el
mismo camino de esta forma amigos lenin
moreno se encontró un ecuador repleto de
problemas y donde los ingresos públicos
pues ya no bastaban para pagar las
cuentas así que en ese momento la
decisión que tomó el nuevo presidente
fue hacer por así decirlo borrón y
cuenta nueva de tal manera que al poco
de llegar al poder comenzó a romper toda
relación con su predecesor una ruptura
con su mentor que quiso escenificar por
todo lo alto
entre las primeras decisiones de lenin
moreno estuvieron sacar a ecuador de
unasur el bloque económico de los países
del foro de sao paulo sacarlo del alba
la alianza bolivariana para los pueblos
de nuestra américa creada por el
mismísimo hugo chávez reconocer a juan
guaidó como presidente legítimo de
venezuela acabar con el asilo de julian
assage en la embajada de ecuador en
londres y restablecer una buena relación
bilateral con eeuu un proceso que por
cierto culminó con una inesperada
reunión entre el presidente ecuatoriano
y donald trump en febrero de 2020
también destituyó a su vicepresidente
jorge glass tan sólo dos meses después
de tomar posesión del cargo glass fue
también vicepresidente con rafael
correa- y fue acusado de recibir 13 5
millones de dólares en sobornos de la
famosa constructora brasileña odebrecht
en otras palabras tal y como podéis ver
lenin moreno llevó a cabo una ruptura
prácticamente total con el legado con
revista
[Música]
y aunque lo cierto es que ninguna de
esas primeras acciones consistieron
realmente reformas económicas sí que
enviaron un mensaje de que él no era
correa algo que por ejemplo quizás fuese
de gran ayuda a la hora de que el país
pudiera acceder de nuevo a préstamos
multimillonarios en condiciones más que
razonables de organismos internacionales
como el fmi o el banco mundial de 1 de
febrero de 2019 ecuador anuncia
préstamos internacionales por 10 mil
millones de dólares por supuesto o tal y
como os podéis imaginar el dinero tenía
un fin concreto respaldar el conocido
como plan de prosperidad del gobierno
ecuatoriano un plan de reformas que
suponía desmontar pieza a pieza buena
parte del legado correísta incluidos
muchos de los subsidios existentes lo
que como veremos marcaría la segunda
mitad de su presidencia pero dicho esto
ya ahora que ya sabemos cómo y por qué
rompió con su predecesor la pregunta que
todos podemos hacernos la pregunta que
seguro muchos estáis haciendo es ese
cuadro y un país mejor que hace cuatro
años
un gobierno dos etapas
a la presidencia de lenin moreno se
puede dividir en dos periodos bien
definidos un primer periodo comprendido
entre los años 2017 y 2019 y un segundo
período entre los años 2019 y 2021 el
primero de estos dos periodos se
caracterizó tal y como ya os hemos
contado por una ruptura abrupta y total
con el correísmo y por el intento de
sacar adelante reformas económicas
destinadas a recuperar la confianza de
los mercados de hecho poco después de
llegar al poder en septiembre de 2017
moreno anunció su primer gran plan para
el país su programa económico para los
próximos cuatro años
este programa incluía entre otras cosas
un aumento del 22 al 25 por ciento del
impuesto de la renta para las sociedades
con alguna que otra exención para las
pequeñas empresas la eliminación de la
ley de plusvalía para intentar impulsar
la construcción o el incremento de
aranceles sobre 375 bienes como medida
proteccionista en el terreno de la
austeridad se fijó el objetivo de
reducir el déficit al 1 por ciento en
2020 con medidas como la reducción del
10% en los salarios de funcionarios de
alto rango o la congelación en las
nuevas contrataciones en el sector
público entre otras
en otras palabras hablamos de un plan
que bien podríamos encajar en el marco
de unas políticas de centroizquierda
moderadas que entienden que de jugarse
sin límite pues nunca es una buena
alternativa asimismo este primer periodo
estuvo también marcado por la lucha
contra la corrupción lo que no nos
engañemos además de ser algo
relativamente popular también es
importante a la hora de hacer negocios
cuanto más limpio es un país y más lo
parece pues mejor que mejor nadie quiere
dejar su dinero en manos de otro danés
pues bien el caso es que para llevar a
cabo esta batalla moreno se valió de dos
grandes herramientas por un lado el
referéndum constitucional y la consulta
popular que se celebraron en febrero del
año 2018 y por otro lado una ley
anticorrupción aprobada en diciembre de
2020 con la primera moreno incluso un
cambio para que la propia constitución
del país prohibiera las candidaturas a
cargos públicos de personas condenadas
por delitos de corrupción además en esta
consulta también se aprobaron cosas como
por ejemplo el límite de reelección para
todas las autoridades electas o la
derogación de la propia ley de plusvalía
en segundo lugar la ley anticorrupción
de 2020 busca imponer nuevos controles
sobre la contratación pública y la
corrupción del sector privado una ley
que aunque moreno lo niega todo apunta
que fue una de las exigencias
para prestar la ecuador otros dos mil
millones de dólares y bueno qué queréis
que os diga al fin y al cabo si quieres
mi dinero o digo yo que lo primero que
tendría que hacer pues es asegurarme de
que lo pongo buenas manos no os parece
de cajón ahora bien otra cosa es que
luego todas estas medidas pues al final
termine introduciéndose no en resultados
reales eso amigos es algo que sólo el
tiempo podrá juzgar pero de entrada el
cambio constitucional le impidió a
rafael correa- condenado por corrupción
intentar regresar al poder al menos
directamente pero aquí no termina todo
durante la presidencia de moreno también
se han dado pasos en otras materias como
por ejemplo la libertad de prensa
moreno prometió durante su campaña
electoral modificar la ley orgánica de
comunicación de 2013 una ley del
presidente correa que determinaba que la
comunicación era un servicio público y
le rogaba al gobierno la autoridad para
regular el contenido de los medios e
investigar y sancionar a periodistas y
lenin cumplió la asamblea nacional
aprobó en 2018 una modificación que
entró en vigor al año siguiente y que
entre otras cosas eliminó la conocida
como super com la superintendencia de
comunicaciones el órgano sancionador de
medios de comunicación que tanto gustaba
el gobierno de rafael correa
[Música]
pues bien este primer periodo en el que
como veis creo que es justo decir se
produjeron muchos avances llegó a su fin
en el año 2019 y la pregunta es qué pasó
en ese momento para que hablemos de un
cambio de periodo pues ponte el cinturón
porque aquí justo aquí es donde llegan
las curvas atentos
el decreto el punto de inflexión
bien como habéis visto la presidencia de
lenin moreno arrancó con todo el mundo
pensando que veríamos una reedición de
las políticas de correa y en cambio
terminó siendo una especie de transición
inesperada ya sabéis lo que viene a ser
una tradición para unos y un cambio
insuficiente para otros de esta forma la
credibilidad en la palabra del
presidente moreno cayó del 67 por ciento
en agosto del 2017 hasta un mínimo del
10,4 por ciento en octubre de 2019
momento en el que moreno además anunció
el famoso decreto 883 un decreto que
eliminaba las subvenciones a los
combustibles y que marcó el inicio de la
caída en picado de su popularidad
el presidente ecuatoriano presentó esta
medida como una de las herramientas para
reducir el déficit y poder así controlar
el aumento de la deuda pública y es que
el tema de los subsidios a los
combustibles en ecuador no es un asunto
menor y es que ecuador lleva
subvencionando los combustibles desde
mucho antes de rafael correa de hecho
desde hace mucho más tiempo más de 40
años ni más ni menos que desde 1974 sin
embargo 11 días después del inicio de
las violentas protestas que se
produjeron por el intento de eliminar el
subsidio a los combustibles moreno
decidió regular y derogar el polémico
decreto 883
[Música]
y es que claro a ver deshacerse de
subsidios que llevan décadas en vigor
por muy ineficientes e inadecuados que
sean resulta una tarea casi imposible
especialmente si pretendes hacerlo sin
enfadar a buena parte de la población
por ejemplo para que os hagáis una idea
eliminar estos subsidios provocó que los
precios del diésel se duplicarán y los
de la gasolina normal se incrementarán
en más de un 25% así que os podéis
imaginar el enfado descomunal en buena
parte de los ecuatorianos sin embargo un
momento amigos porque a pesar de ello
ecuador seguía teniendo el precio de la
gasolina más barato de toda
latinoamérica y no nos engañemos
mantener esta subvención tiene un precio
muy pero que muy elevado los subsidios a
los combustibles en ecuador suponen un
gasto de unos 3500 millones de dólares
cada año lo que viene a suponer algo más
del 3% del pib y más del 20 por ciento
de todos los ingresos por las
exportaciones de petróleo además para
colmo este tipo de fórmulas incentivan
un consumo mucho más alto de crudo lo
que eleva asimismo el coste de estas
políticas públicas es decir en otras
palabras eliminar estos subsidios era
una de las medidas estrella para
conseguir equilibrar las cuentas
públicas así que tal y como os podéis
imaginar la derogación del decreto 883
por completo las previsiones de
reducción de déficit con las que
trabajaba el gobierno y para colmo del
daño pues ya estaba hecho a pesar de no
conseguir su objetivo el coste político
fue inevitable para unos por aprobarlo y
para otros por derogar lo el caso es que
la popularidad de moreno se hundió del
77 por ciento que tenía el inicio de su
presidencia a menos del 10 por ciento y
no desde entonces no ha levantado cabeza
eso sí todo se ha dicho a pesar de todos
los problemas el gobierno siguió
avanzando por esta misma línea el 24 de
septiembre de 2020 el gobierno libera
importación de combustibles para el
sector privado petroecuador pierde el
monopolio en la compra y venta de
derivados para el sector industrial la
emergencia de coronavirus propicia la
liberalización del precio de la gasolina
en ecuador'
el gobierno aplicará desde julio un
sistema de bandas de precios con un
techo y con un suelo si el combustible
fluctúa por debajo las gasolineras
cobrarán ese mínimo al consumidor y el
monto excedente irá a las arcas públicas
si la cotización internacional sube más
allá de un 5 por ciento de un mes para
otro
entonces activarán los subsidios
estatales para que los ciudadanos no
sientan el encarecimiento y se vale no
se puede decir que esto sea
estrictamente una liberalización de
precios puesto que el gobierno sigue
imponiendo
a un precio mínimo y siguen contemplando
los subsidios sin embargo a pesar de
todo supone un importante ahorro para
las arcas públicas que algunas fuentes
han aproximado a los mil millones de
dólares anuales el caso es que como veis
moreno heredó una difícil situación
económica terminaba la bonanza petrolera
le tocó jugar con las peores cartas y
para colmo llegó el coronavirus ecuador
enfrenta el momento más crítico de su
historia al impacto de los efectos de la
pandemia se suma una economía debilitada
debilitada por el endeudamiento
irresponsable y la corrupción galopante
del gobierno anterior
y el crecimiento económico en 2019 antes
de coronavirus ya fue de un irrisorio 01
el pib y ecuatoriano se contrajo un 9
por ciento en 2020 y los pronósticos
apuntan a que no se volverá a niveles de
crecimiento sólidos hasta al menos el
año 2024 lo que ha tenido como primera
consecuencia el incremento de los
niveles de pobreza hasta superar el
nivel del 30% de la población además la
drástica caída en los ingresos
petroleros la principal fuente de
divisas para ecuador ha hecho que a
pesar de todas las reformas el gobierno
se haya visto forzado a seguir escalando
en la enorme montaña de deuda que ya
arrastra la economía ecuatoriana
queridos amigos a pesar del giro de
timón 500 protagonizar el cni moreno lo
cierto es que la suerte no ha estado de
su lado y ahora durante los próximos
años el siguiente gobierno se enfrenta a
una sociedad muy polarizada un país cada
vez más dependiente de los acreedores
internacionales y una enorme falta de
visibilidad económica hacia dónde se
dirige el ecuador en fin sólo el tiempo
lo dirá pero de momento turno para ti
cómo valoras los intentos reformistas de
la etapa de moreno crees que fueron
suficientes o que por contra se quedaron
cortos como crees que debió enfrentarse
a las protestas de finales del 2019 qué
esperas del próximo gobierno déjanos tu
respuesta por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ya sabéis si este vídeo ha
resultado interesante
no olvides darle al botón de like y
suscribir te avisa al político una vez
más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]